we knew it was coming it was just kind
of figuring out when when the right time
was and this feels this feels like the
right time to us people are ready it
just feels right it's been a while since
we've you know worked on this on this
title people are starting to put their
old consoles away when we went back to
play it we discovered a couple things
how much fun it wasn't how much we loved
it you know I've been on the team has
been in bands since forever so far short
it fell of the original goals that we
had for rock there if you want to egg
game about being in a band
any time we put out a game and half the
responses are great we're rapping for
word you know not being a good sister
cool but we're obviously the people to
make it we're not doing rocking because
we have to we have 2168 songs we're not
doing any rock band game because someone
told us to that we're prepping to to
bring over we're making a new rock band
because we want to make a new rock band
it feels almost like coming home
[Music]
the makeup of the team that we have
right now feels a lot like it did back
in you know the early 2000 no one's
needs to have written down anywhere how
all this is supposed to I've never felt
more like I work at an indie studio than
like right now we're driving towards all
of our own decisions we're choosing
what's best for the projects of our own
accord like we don't have external
people really driving those decisions
for us so it you know even though things
kind of get kind of crazy it feels
really good because we're still in
control of it doesn't do anything else
either but like it pops up and the
meetings going slow
[Music]
the studio vibe compared to where it was
a few years ago is unbelievably
energized everyone in the studio has
that kind of like that creative recharge
where you know we don't we're not
responsible to anyone but ourselves we
don't have to answer to anyone but our
own kind of like create a vision
creative band-aids and we have a great
relationship with MTV they had a lot of
opinions about where the game should go
and they were good opinions but it also
made it difficult for us to follow our
instincts a lot of times and and one of
the things that I'm most excited about
is the way in which this game will
reflect the character of the people that
are working on it to us rock band 4 is
about expanding on the feeling that you
are playing with your your your band
mates and you're playing a live game you
know rock band is all about the fantasy
of being a rock star and being in a band
and getting to feel like you're playing
music and being expressive the stuff
that we've been able to add to the core
experience really is like a truer
version of what we originally had in
mind
rock band 3 had tons of things in it
it's something for everyone basically
you know in retrospect I think we
innovated in a lot of areas that were
not necessarily the right ones we're
really trying very hard this time around
to be very creative in ways that will
impact everybody in the band we are
making it an attempt to stay as focused
as we can I'm really I mean I'm hoping
that we can surprise people with the
kinds of things that we can accomplish
Rockman has been trying to like the
quintessential party game and I think
you'll see just you know a lot of energy
around the gameplay that's in rock band
4 there's a lot of stuff percolating in
our in our feature set that that we
really want to talk about and figuring
out how to do that frankly is like you
know a tremendous amount of work and
work that we're still doing which is why
we're not talking about those kinds of
feature details now
- no - that the table person that
responded to this survey it probably
erupted and anyway expect the results to
be that degree the survey we put out has
had over sixty seven thousand people who
respond to we actually got a lot of user
info from not just the rock band
community which is nice you know it's
like who owns all PLC and what consoles
are they it's pretty clear that people
want to use their existing instruments
that's fair and it's pretty clear that
people like if they purchase songs they
want access to the songs they already
bought we have so many users that one
spent a lot of money but ii would love
our games so much that they have all of
our content that is possibly available
literally all of it and we want to we
want to be good buy that brand-new
engine with a lot of new graphical
capabilities and new audio capabilities
we've actually involved the franchise so
we can push ourselves harder creatively
there is some evolution of the way that
you play that's in this game that really
wouldn't have been possible if we made
the game a couple of years ago
expectations are really complicated when
it comes to Rockman because our our
audience is so diverse now we're we're
very indeed in the past we have like
bigger teams and sort of like the
corporate overlords and a lot of
different masters that we had to serve
video game industry is tough as hell you
know the stakes are really high for the
studio that can be stressful for people
but I also think it brings out the best
in people
rock band is a big bet for us because
you know we think it has the potential
to hit a lot of people and to improve a
lot of people's video gaming experiences
you know
[Music]
and we hope it does well
you
[Music]